president biden's motorcade arrived
early at the nato headquarters for the
first of a trio of summits
the u.s president is so often said to be
the leader of the free world and today
joe biden represented just that leading
a group of nations together united
against unprecedented russian aggression
we're told the mood among the 30 leaders
whose countries make up the nato
alliance has been sober and resolute
look i think that the reality is that uh
vladimir putin has already crossed the
red line into into barbarism this
illegal brutal invasion
of a friendly democracy in ukraine
by vladimir putin is absolutely
unacceptable
around the table they agreed to double
troop numbers in eastern europe to
bolster nuclear and chemical defenses to
provide ukraine with more weapons
together all of it is a stark reflection
of the state of peace and stability on
the continent right now avara video link
from kiev ukraine's president was beamed
into the heart of this western alliance
this time with a precise list of weapons
he says he needs
you can give us one percent of all your
planes one percent of all your tanks
just one percent we can't just buy that
such supplies depend on a political
decision from nato
the nato chief wouldn't be drawn on the
details of weapons to ukraine but was
clear that the alliance needs urgently
to adapt to a new reality and he was
blunt on the need to defend itself
against the russian nuclear threat
our top military commander general
walters has activated nato's chemical
biological
radiological and nuclear
defense elements
and allies are deploying additional
chemical and biological and nuclear
defenses to reinforce our existing and
new baking groups
a prospect which should be so
unthinkable is now troublingly front and
center there is a visceral horror of the
use of these weapons of mass destruction
uh i think that if putin were to
engage in anything like that uh the
consequences would be very very uh
severe you have to uh have a bit of
ambiguity about your
about your response but i think it would
be
catastrophic for him if he were to do
that and i i think that he i think that
he understands that
ambiguity seems clearly to be the tactic
such as the jeopardy
we would respond we would respond if he
uses it the nature of the response would
depend on the nature of the use the
demonstration why i asked for this nato
meeting today is to be sure
that after a month we will sustain what
we're doing not just next month the
following month but for the remainder of
this entire year that's what will stop
him
the g7 ended up as a hastily arranged
gathering in the nato building the
pledge there was to strictly enforce
growing and aligned sanctions against
russia
across town at the european council the
protest to greet the u.s president as he
arrived as the guest at the eu summit
these meetings together do represent the
most important series of diplomatic
gatherings in decades not since world
war ii have things felt so perilous on
this continent and yet despite the unity
the resolve the solidarity and yet more
sanctions the troubling reality is that
the bloodshed in ukraine continues and
the broader threats from russia well
they are worryingly acute
as leaders they have been forced to
confront challenges not felt for quite a
few generations on their shoulders rest
huge decisions and such troubling
calculations mark stone sky news in
brussels